[Música]
estrictamente regulado desde hace dos
años debido a la pandemia
el carnaval de guadalupe suele ser una
cita ineludible en las islas de enero a
marzo los guadalupeños viven al ritmo de
los desfiles conducidos por decenas de
grupos de voluntarios para todos los
participantes en el carnaval suele ser
la culminación de un año de duro trabajo
unos días antes de la gran final los
miembros de la huacachina iban buscan la
inspiración para rematar sus trajes
esperan encontrar una verdadera joya
sacar más a relucir el motivo sacarlo a
relucir con el blanco echemos un vistazo
al blanco los bailarines no verán los
trajes hasta unos días antes y
tiene miedo de que alguien le robe sus
ideas y sucede
sucedió con la tela una vez reservamos
nuestra tela y luego en el desfile vimos
un grupo con la misma tela que la
nuestra eso no nos gusta
así que los disfraces son siempre una
sorpresa una sorpresa total pero
confiamos en él sabemos que no nos
veremos feos el precio los bailarines
pagan por su propio vestuario por lo que
hay que buscar un equilibrio entre el
costo y el diseño
intentamos no superar los 160 dólares
su mundo
[Música]
sólo quedan tres días para terminar los
trajes y son los sombreros los que más
trabajo le están dando a elodie para
cada desfile el grupo elige un tema este
año el grupo de concierto será dulce
aquí hay dulces y también los tendremos
en nuestros collares seremos chicas
azucarazo
estarán listos encontraremos la manera
nosotros lucharemos tal vez pero lo
haremos
[Música]
para el grupo cacique la noche será
larga
[Música]
la coreógrafa está afinando los últimos
detalles y el ambiente es tenso
ha tenido que cambiar algunos
movimientos por ahora
sus tropas no llevan el compás
[Música]
no no no no no no está mal no no nada
bueno no tenemos que arreglar algunas
cosas pero en general está listo usted
es muy estricta sí siempre siempre
cuando trabajo no del todo siempre por
supuesto
la noche está lejos de terminar porque
mañana desfilan en concierto
que no será mariana así es un paseo
hoy es un día extenuante y crucial 40
grupos se enfrentarán en las calles de
conciertos
una oportunidad inesperada para que los
turistas conozcan a los participantes en
el carnaval
es fabuloso los colores la alegría son
todos cuando optimistas es fantástico
volverse 4 de la tarde es hora de
empezar el audi y olivier terminaron los
accesorios durante la noche así que el
traje finalmente está listo por fin todo
listo para salir ganarán eso esperamos
está muy lejos de los carnavales de los
años 60 o incluso de los años 80 cuando
los músicos y bailarines improvisaban
disfraces con trapos y cuerdas a lo
largo de los años los desfiles se han
ido sofisticando
[Música]
18 horas la noche cae suavemente sobre
gozar
[Música]
y es el turno de elodie el agua que se
levanta de pavonearse
[Música]
la llegada a la alfombra roja es el
momento que más temen los grupos
se trata de meses de trabajo
tienen dos minutos y medio para dejar
boquiabiertos a los jueces
[Música]
los premios en juego honran a los grupos
y a sus barrios
al final del carnaval los premios
ascienden a miles de dólares se sientan
felices creen que ganaron el primer
puesto eso esperamos hicimos todo lo que
pudimos y trabajamos muy duro
adiós
hoy se cuestione o kuwait
[Aplausos]
ahora es el turno del grupo de natalina
coreógrafa para pasar ante los jueces
pusieron hasta la última gota de energía
en la batalla
algunos minutos se juzga todo la música
los disfraces y el baile
les ha ido bien
todos empresas motivación ambiente todo
huacachi lehman y casi terminan tercer y
cuarto respectivamente
los participantes tendrán que esperar
otro año
para volver a intentar ganar el primer
puesto
y